hello
my name is florian holm
i'm here to tell you about a little book
which enables me to be here to speak
with you
because i have a bullet lodged in my
back from an assassination attempt this
is florian harm
he's a millionaire playboy hedge fund
manager turned fugitive in the early
2000s investigators caught on to his
penny stock pump and dump scheme and he
was put on the fbi's most wanted list
along the way he started his own hedge
fund invested in a brothel and even
saved a football club from bankruptcy at
the pinnacle of his success he had a net
worth of 700 million dollars
then in 2007 he vanished without a trace
he stuffed five hundred thousand dollars
in his underwear briefcase and cigar box
boarded one of his private jets and
disappeared from the world stage
this is the story of how a millionaire
playboy hedge fund manager escaped the
fbi
florian was born on october 7 1959 in a
small town near frankfurt germany
florian came from an affluent family and
had a good upbringing his father owned a
successful pipe welding and bathroom
fittings installation business but
florian didn't want to take on his
father's business he instead wanted to
follow in the footsteps of his great
uncle joseph neckerman his uncle was a
german male order tycoon and equestrian
joseph represented germany in the
olympics from 1960 to 1972
and on top of all that joseph started
germany's largest mail order business at
the time and employed around 30 000
employees
his great uncle joseph hosted family
gatherings at his mansion every sunday
these visits inspired florian and gave
him the motivation to become rich and
successful
florian was sent to the us he performed
well in high school and was accepted
into harvard university he even
represented the harvard basketball team
in 1987 florian graduated from harvard
business school with an mba and got a
job at the prestigious merrill lynch
he worked at merrill lynch for a couple
of years but he eventually switched over
to fidelity investments where he got the
opportunity to work under and be
personally trained by peter lynch a
mutual fund legend
after working with peter lynch florian
moved back to germany where he would
become a senior vice president at julius
bar
but florian had bigger ambitions and in
1993 he decided to start his first
company value management and research
based in frankfurt germany his company
went public in 1998 within a couple of
years the company's value had risen
seven-fold while the dot-com bubble was
getting inflated
he drew a lot of attention due to his
charm brashness and glamour he also had
a very unique investment philosophy
florian invested in internet and
technology hype stocks and thanks to the
dot-com bubble these stocks would
skyrocket he became known for these
investments and his stocks were often
referred to as hom stocks after he made
a fortune from the dotcom bubble he
began to spend his newfound fortune in
2004 he saved the german football club
borisia dortmund from bankruptcy the
club was struggling financially and
suffered from poor management florian
invested 20 million dollars and helped
overthrow the old management he was
hailed as a hero by many of the fans in
2005 he co-founded absolute capital
management which was listed on the
alternative investment market of the
london stock exchange
given his popularity charm and
investment strategy investors flooded in
one of his most infamous investments was
a brothel in berlin called artemis by
2007 acm was managing 3 billion
and florian's personal fortune was an
estimated 700 million dollars but his
success in the stock market attracted
some unwanted attention
in 2006 florian was traveling through
the streets of caracas venezuela he got
stopped by a group of armed men the
armed men demanded everything flory had
had on him florian handed over his phone
and wallet but he didn't want to let go
of his watch when florian tried
negotiating to keep his watch the
armored men started shooting florian was
shot in his chest and ended up losing
most of his left lung and spleen florian
suspects that it was an assassination
attempt
after the experience florian got a bit
of a wake-up call and he began to
re-evaluate his life choices at the time
he had already built up a fortune but
spent most of his time at work so he had
all the money in the world but no time
to spend it so in september of 2007
florian announced that he would be
selling his stake in acm and retiring he
abruptly announced his resignation as
the head of acm and disappeared the move
wasn't well received acm stock lost 93
of its value up until june 2008
after the sale florian fled the country
and spread his money across 120 bank
accounts located on four different
continents
on a flight from spain to italy he had
five hundred thousand dollars stashed in
his underwear briefcase and cigar box
florian had just gotten away with one of
the biggest frauds in us history
despite all the positive press acm was
receiving the entire fund was basically
a scam
florian was operating a pump and dump
scheme and securities and exchange
commission was catching on the first
form of fraud florian was running was
the classic penny stock pump and dump
between 2004 and 2006 florian had been
using his massive cash reserves to buy
up cheap penny stocks and sold them to
uneducated investors besides the penny
stock scheme he also had a clever way of
making more money on the side florian
had set up a secondary company that was
responsible for executing trades for acm
and his company charged insanely high
fees
so not only was he making money from the
penny stock pump and dump scheme but he
was making money executing trades for
the scheme florian and his partners
would regularly trade stocks amongst
themselves to inflate the daily volume
of these trades and make it seem like
hot stocks driving up the stock price
and selling at a profit
acm saw great performance during a
relatively stagnant period following the
dot-com crash the sec eventually caught
on to the scheme in march 2013 the fbi
filed criminal charges against florian
the fbi the sec and the dea put him on
the most wanted list
florian's freedom was short-lived he was
arrested in florence italy just two days
after the fbi filed criminal charges the
italian police had been tipped off by
the fbi and they were able to locate him
for the arrest
after his arrest his lawyers argued that
florian suffered from multiple sclerosis
and that he couldn't be incarcerated due
to health concerns but doctors testified
that his condition didn't prevent
incarceration the court sided with the
fbi and agreed to extradite florian
which meant he was facing up to 225
years in prison but florian thought up a
clever plan in italy once extradition
becomes final the prisoner must be
extradited within 45 days or they're
released from prison
florian stalled long enough and on june
23 2014 he was released from prison as
soon as he was released he fled to
germany
florian is still on the fbi's most
wanted list and since the german courts
don't have any arrest warrants against
florian florian can live as a free man
as long as he stays in germany
nowadays florian is a changed man
he said his year in italian prison
completely changed his outlook on life
he's quite transparent about his immoral
and unethical activities at acm but he
still believes he didn't break any laws
florian has become a strong christian
and spends most of his time sharing his
knowledge and donating his money he
published a book called rogue financier
and he donated 100 of the profits to
charity he also co-founded a charity
called our ladies message of mercy to
the world foundation which focuses on
strengthening christian values and
supports children with disabilities
he even started his own youtube channel
where he discusses his thoughts on the
world the economy and the stock market
on a regular basis
there's a lesson in every story what can
we learn from florian's insane journey
now of course there's no denying that
the penny stock pump and dump scheme he
ran was immoral and unethical he
swindled investors out of millions of
dollars and was charged with fraud
but he was smart enough to realize that
the ship was sinking while most people
get too caught up in success he was
cautious enough to spot the red flags
and escaped with the money this draws
parallels to the many of the crypto pump
and dump schemes where investors get rug
pulled and are just left bag holding
with investments investors should always
be on the lookout for any red flags or
suspicious activities
some people argue that florian should be
extradited to the us and jailed for his
crimes while others argue that florian
is a changed man and is actually doing
some good for society and making a
positive impact
what do you guys think should he be
jailed for his crimes or should he
maintain his innocence and freedom the
comment section in this one will be very
interesting thanks for staying till the
end of this video if you enjoyed this
video then be sure to hit the like
button drop a comment subscribe and hit
the notification bell for more content
like this also be sure to check out our
other videos on this channel links are
in the description and we'll see you in
the next one